[Music]
welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian Bachmann a 22 year old
man is in police custody arrested
moments after police arrived at the
scene of a mass shooting inside a
nightclub
people inside Club Q in Colorado Springs
say it was chaos inside before night
midnight when a man opened fire the
shooting happened during transgender
Awareness Week in just minutes before
the transgender day of remembrance which
was Sunday the city's mayor says someone
was able to grab the man's handgun and
hit him with it before two other patrons
pinned him to the ground the shooting
itself only lasted around one minute but
unfortunately his bullets found targets
so far the death hole stands at five
officials had revised the number of
injured to 18 of those all but one was
shot more than a dozen are still in the
hospital the gunman is also still in the
hospital court records show Anderson Lee
Aldrich was charged with five counts of
murder and five counts of bias motivated
crime causing bodily injury that's what
Colorado calls hate crimes prosecutors
asked the judge to seal court filings to
protect the investigation Witnesses say
the suspect was heavily armed and where
a military-style flack Jack it will be
owners of club Q say they didn't
recognize him vigils and prayer services
were held all around the city on Sunday
and Colorado's Governor called for Flags
to be flown at half staff
I want to First Express my condolences
to those families who have lost the
loved ones during this tragic event to
those that were injured today during
this tragic shooting
I want every citizen in our city to know
that the men and women of the Colorado
Springs Police Department stand with you
during this tragedy
we are working tirelessly to ensure that
Justice for the victims in this
senseless meaningful shooting is given
Club Q is a safe haven for our lgbtq
citizens
every citizen has the right to feel safe
and secure in our city
to go about our beautiful city
without fear of being harmed
or treated poorly
I'm so terribly saddened and heartbroken
joining us today is former Brooklyn
homicide prosecutor and defense attorney
Bernardo villalona and former trial
attorney and co-host Terry Austin
Bernardo an lgbtq bar on drag diva night
at the end of transgender Awareness Week
on top of that the Remembrance Day when
we know this about the shooter is facing
hate crimes is this are these facts
sorry enough to prove the fact that he's
going after this particular group
absolutely Brian on its face alone you
can infer that it was motivated by some
form of hate because this club Club Q is
known to be frequently by the lgbtq
community however what else we're going
to need and hope that the investigation
continues is looking at his social media
looking at his cell phone text messages
conversation and interviews with other
individuals to see what his mindset is a
search up his house to see if he has
anything that is documented all those
things are going to firm up and
straighten the evidence indicates that
it was motivated by hate but as of now
he's charged with first-degree murder as
well as hate crimes and what he's
looking at is life on the first degree
murder but we'll be watching to see what
other information we get as to what led
this man to go into a club and kill five
people and injured 18 others now Terry
those are State charges with the FBI
investigating this should we expect
federal charges and what could those be
I definitely think that we will see
federal charges the fact that the FBI is
already investigating this means that
they think there's something there you
know the hate crimes law was first
passed in 1968 but it was enhanced back
in 1968 it just included crimes that are
based on race color creed but now we
have in 2009 a law that basically will
protect the LGBT community and gender so
I think that they're going to look at
this as a hate crime under federal law
yeah we'll see what state and federal
charges come about this more could be
added of course to both well the man who
opened fire at a Buffalo New York
supermarket in May will not have to
appear in court yet for what's expected
to be a guilty plea New York Court
officials announced that because of bad
weather including several feet of snow
Court was adjourned Monday the shooter a
self-proclaimed white supremacist
planned to plead guilty to State charges
he's accused of killing 10 black people
out of Tops Market grocery store in
Buffalo the terrorism and hate crime
charges he faces have a mandatory
sentence of life with without parole a
Federal grand jury has also indicted the
shooter on domestic terrorism and murder
charges Monday's court appearance was
moved to January 23rd
family and loved ones said goodbye over
the weekend to shanquella Robinson the
woman who died from a severed spine
while on vacation in cattle san Luke in
Cabo San Lucas Mexico the FBI is now
investigating Robinson's death the 26
year old from Charlotte North Carolina
was on vacation when she was found
unconscious in her rental home on
October 29th a service was held for
Robinson on Saturday in Charlotte her
family says they were originally told
her cause of death was alcohol poisoning
but according to her death certificate
she died because of a severed spinal
cord injury in intervention from the FBI
is rare according to a former assistant
director of the agency and is only taken
when there's a reasonable belief that a
crime was committed
we turn now to Federal Court where a
judge sentenced there knows founder
Elizabeth Holmes to 11 years in prison
this follows home's conviction of three
counts of wire fraud back in January
theranos once believed to be worth nine
billion dollars promised to change the
blood testing game with small samples
and quick results but prosecutors argued
that the only success came from Holmes
and her ex-boyfriend Ramesh Sunny bawani
defrauding investors out of Millions
Holmes has accused her ex-boyfriend and
former therano CEO of abusing her
throughout the company's operation
mawani was tried in July and found
guilty of two conspiracy charges and 10
counts of wire fraud his sentencing is
set for December 7th as for homes she
will report to prison on April 27 2023.
welcome back to law and crime daily
there was uproar over the weekend after
a Ticketmaster meltdown and the
cancellation of Taylor Swift ticket
sales on Thursday Ticketmaster canceled
its public sales of Taylor Swift's
arrows tour after things went wild
during the pre-sales Ticketmaster says
there was quote extraordinarily High
demands on ticket systems and
insufficient
is his first tour in five years the
problems with ticket sales put
Ticketmaster and its parent company Live
Nation entertainment back in the
spotlight the justice department
recently opened an investigation focused
on whether Live Nation is violating
antitrust laws one ticket resale website
like StubHub and sells individual
tickets for between 600 dollars for the
back row in Las Vegas to three thousand
dollars for front row in Atlanta
Ticketmaster says its systems had to
handle more than 3 billion requests
meaning some people in the virtual queue
had to deal with the site crashing when
they actually made it to the purchasing
page it's unclear when Ticketmaster will
reopen sales for Taylor Swift's tour or
if there was even any tickets left after
the pre-sale blowout
Terry I say this as the husband of a
Swifty just asking to play Devil's
Advocate so don't come for me anyone but
how do we go from Swifty's not getting
tickets to it being a legal issue well
it's a legal issue because it's an
Anti-Trust issue ironically Brian we
know that the doj approved in 2010 the
merger of these two companies now
they're investigating Live Nation to see
whether or not they have violated any
Anti-Trust laws meaning that they have a
monopoly and they are not you know
dealing with the Public's interest in
mind they are saying that they are
really doing the right thing and they
take these laws very seriously and of
course Taylor Swift is left in the
Middle with the difficulty here of
getting these tickets sold well so the
doj okays at first and now they're
coming after them sounds like a lot of
bad blood but Bernardo let's say the doj
is successful what does that mean for a
Ticketmaster and people who didn't get
their tickets I'm just asking for a
friend whose wife has asking
well the problem with that Brian is that
you're not going to be able to tell look
at an accurate list of all those
individuals that were actually in queue
looking to buy those tickets so that's
going to be difficult to determine so I
doubt that there will be any payout or
settlement having to do with them I
think that there'll be a broad type of
settlement in the sense of look
Ticketmaster Live Nation you're going to
have to come up with some kind of
agreement to avoid this from ever
happening again and some stiff fines so
it seems like there are never ever
getting back together in terms of those
tickets so we'll see how that case goes